the world is now battling more than 11
million cases of the corona virus the
global death toll tops five hundred and
twenty five thousand this morning in
England the lifting of covent
restrictions today is being referred to
as Super Saturday people who are eager
to get their hair cut can return to hair
salons and barbershops and those in need
of a pint or two can finally go back to
their favourite pubs Roxana Saberi is in
London Roxana good morning to you good
morning Jeff the Greyhound opens its
doors just a few minutes ago for the
first time in more than three months but
things look a little different for
example you could see they've mounted up
plexiglass in front of the bar at pubs
and restaurants across the country it
won't be business as usual government
guidelines encourage guests to reserved
tables in advance when customers arrive
staff should register their names and
numbers and keep that information for
three weeks to help trace any infections
groups should be limited to six people
spaced at least three or so feet apart
and live gigs and standing at the bar
are not allowed wearing masks will be
optional one english city that won't be
joining in the festivities is leicester
the city of around three hundred
thousand went back into lockdown this
week because of a spike in infections
authorities are warning that other
cities could face the same fate if
people aren't careful they've also
threatened to close beaches after
thousands of people walked to the coast
last weekend to enjoy the hot weather
Britain has the highest coated 19 death
toll in Europe and the country's top
scientists warned yesterday the pandemic
is a long way from gone churches and
cinemas also are reopening today as did
hair salons at midnight last night so
people can show off their new haircuts
at pubs like this Michelle yeah I could
really use a new dude like Stannis a
very a cut certainly thank you